the 71st annual Academy Awards brought
to you by American Express whether
you're seeing a movie or making one we
can help you do more kodak take pictures
further
Sears come see the softer side of Sears
and Revlon revolutionary products for
revolutionary women
okay now Shakespeare really strolling
over in his grave in Shakespeare and
loved sandy Powell's passion for details
shines through in her representation of
the 16th century styles worn by theater
folk and by the court of Queen Elizabeth
you think this is easy
I haven't had to take my dress off this
many times since my first audition
Stephen you remember how many times I
took it
I'm just kidding man you know they know
now I really have a huge dry-cleaning
bill bigger than you know but
everybody's got yeah you know it was
coming you knew it was coming
everybody's got a bigger dry-cleaning
bill and she does now that you've seen
the five films nominated it's time for
the award for best costume design and I
get to present it over the objections of
the designers who feel I've done more
than enough for their costumes already
but they want to know so they've got the
deal with it
once again the nominees are Colleen
Atwood for beloved
Alexandria burn for Elizabeth
Julianna makovski for Pleasantville
sandy power for Shakespeare in law
Andy Powell for Velvets gold
and the Oscar goes to Sandeep our
Oscar for Sandy Powell who was
previously nominated for wings of a dove
and Orlando
but I'd like to congratulate will people
having the guts to wear that velvet
goldmine costume
okay well two nominations one speech and
I want to thank everybody eyewear with
on both films there are too many names
it will be too boring but really this
mostly is my brilliant fantastic team
that work with me on everything thank
you everybody thank you